[Música]
hola bienvenidos aquí a américa un
magazine de france 24 en el que
revisamos las principales noticias de
nuestro continente mi nombre es andrés
meza muñoz y estoy aquí en reemplazo de
mi compañera natalia cabrera y estas son
nuestras historias de hoy empezamos en
el norte del continente méxico porque la
desaparición de de baní escobar en
monterrey desata la indignación por la
violencia machista en el país y lo que
es considerado como la incapacidad del
gobierno de andrés manuel lópez obrador
de hacer justicia en feminicidios y
bajamos hasta centroamérica donde el
estado de excepción fue extendido por
otros 30 días más en el salvador más de
20.000 personas han sido arrestadas
según el gobierno se trata de
pandilleros pero organizaciones
defensoras de los derechos humanos
argumentan que no todos lo son
y hablamos de la guerra en ucrania que
aunque no está en nuestro continente lo
impacta revisamos como la industria de
los diamantes en eeuu ha cambiado por el
embargo a la importación de productos
rusos
empezamos en mexico el caso de the bank
y escobar causa indignación en el país
la joven desapareció el 9 de abril y fue
hallada sin vida 13 días después en un
tanque de agua de un motel ubicado en
los suburbios de la ciudad de monterrey
en el estado de nuevo léon epicentro de
la industria del país los vídeos de sus
últimas horas de vida revelan que se
enfrentó a un grupo de hombres veamos
más en el informe de natalia cabrera y
luis fernando montes se asomó a la afp
de baní escobar es la más reciente
víctima de violencia de género y nuevo
león el estado mexicano en el que tan
sólo en los cuatro primeros meses de
2022 han desaparecido al menos 300
mujeres
el hallazgo del cuerpo de la joven que
estaba desaparecida generó protestas
tanto en la próspera ciudad de monterrey
como en méjico la capital para exigir
justicia para todas vienen porque estoy
como todas muy enojada muy indignada y
con mucho miedo de seguir viviendo en un
país en donde pasa lo que le pasó a de
baño el presidente andrés manuel lópez
obrador ofreció apoyo federal
el gobernador aceptó
desde que lo planteé aquí
un equipo del gobierno federal
coadyuvar a participar
en el proceso de investigación
y
este ya se está haciendo y cuando
tengamos
nosotros más información
se va a dar a conocer pero
organizaciones defensoras de los
derechos denuncian que el mandatario no
ha hecho lo suficiente para proteger a
las mujeres en todo el país según cifras
entregadas por su propio gobierno se
desconoce el paradero de 24.000 de ellas
y en 2021 se registraron más de 1000
feminicidios en 2020 fueron asesinadas
en promedio 10 mujeres cada día es un
problema realmente sistémico en sales a
la calle y te
enfrentas por ejemplo a la publicidad
en los pósters que hay dimensiones
espectaculares con retratos de mujeres
hipersexualizadas o con una manera de
vivir el ser hombre que también es un
cuerpo bastante específico
el hombre de amor perfecto que
evidentemente el tema de la masculina
también cruzada los machismos o aprendes
del acoso callejero o el acoso laboral
el acoso escolar o sea el machismo es un
problema realmente que va más allá de
los hogares otra cosa que es muy
importante decir es que no es un tema
solamente de méxico la solución a este
flagelo pasa precisamente por ellos es
muy importante que construyamos
relaciones más sanas y los sombras
tienen que de alguna manera romper
ciertos pactos
lo que se llama la rabia de la
masculinidad que son sus actos
patriarcales entre amigos entre hermanos
en los que la amistad entre los hombres
es mucho más importante mucho más fuerte
que el bienestar de las mujeres o de las
personas que son disidentes
de asistencia sexuales digamos las
personas a la gente y en ese aspecto un
muy buen una muy buena forma de comenzar
sin duda es dejar de hacer bromas
machistas pero también observarse en
tratarse emocionalmente comenzar por
dejar de hacer bromas machistas es según
expertas uno de los primeros pasos
vamos ahora a el salvador que cumplió un
mes bajo el estado de excepción
declarado por el presidente en allí
bukele bajo el argumento de controlar la
violencia de pandillas la medida que le
otorga poderes especiales fue extendida
por otros 30 días más el gobierno
informó que más de 20.000 supuestos
pandilleros han sido detenidos desde que
entró en vigor sin embargo algunas
organizaciones defensoras de los
derechos humanos denuncian que no todos
hacen parte de las llamadas maras desde
que se adoptó la medida los países
fronterizos elevaron sus controles
migratorios en guatemala por ejemplo el
ejército patrulla constantemente el área
para evitar el ingreso de mareros como
se les conoce en centroamérica pero las
familias temen que una vez cumplida la
medida de seguridad el ejército se
repliegue y queden nuevamente
desprotegidas ante la amenaza que
representan las maras nuestros
corresponsales en centroamérica andrés
suárez jaramillo y aurora valle nos
traen la historia
mario gonzález y su familia viven al
frente del río paz que divide a
guatemala del salvador la prórroga del
régimen de excepción salvadoreño le ha
dado 30 días más de tranquilidad a este
campesino que teme que los pandilleros
lleguen algún día a su casa
a caer guatemala al otro lado se puede
ver desde el salvador
el verano centroamericano es la época
propicia para que los mareros crucen
ilegalmente esta frontera porque el río
baja su caudal y permite transitar lo
uno voltea a ver para lado el salvador
es por momento miraba uno que venían ahí
los mareros y entonces uno siente temor
va casi con ella y se llenaba la
cuestión va la mitad mala llevaba de por
miedo con el ejército guatemalteco de
escolta llenar el bidón con agua ahora
es una tarea tranquila esta protección
comenzó a partir de que el gobierno
salvadoreño declaró la guerra contra las
pandillas por la ola de homicidios que
azotó a el salvador en marzo de este año
que dice que lo está agarrando que dice
que hay varios presos yo presiento que
ya no va a ser igual la vida
me calenté la torre
mario y maría elena habían desalojado su
casa luego de conocer el reciente
asesinato de un marero en el río solo
volvieron porque el ejército redobló su
presencia para mitigar el cruce ilegal
de mareros
firme
no ha visto ustedes de movimiento de
personas extrañas
muy bien el comandante del ejército de
guatemala a cargo de la seguridad de la
frontera con el salvador da un parte de
tranquilidad sin desestimar que se han
logrado varios arrestos de mareros en
las últimas semanas si de hecho la
población en un momento tuvo temor
verdad por la por la acción de la
república del salvador en este estado de
excepción sin embargo la población ha
confiado en las fuerzas de seguridad en
el ejército de guatemala y está en sus
hogares para los habitantes de la
frontera en guatemala se sienten
vulnerables por que presienten que si el
ejército abandona el área cuando termine
el estado de excepción salvadoreño las
maras podrían regresar a expulsarlos de
sus viviendas a reclutar a los menores e
intimidarlos por la fuerza
cambiamos de tema desde marzo eeuu
prohibió la importación de productos
rusos en represalia a su invasión a
ucrania desde entonces reconocidas y
lujosas marcas como la firma de
diamantes tiffany's han cerrado sus
puertas a los bienes de consumo rusos
nos lo cuenta nuestra corresponsal en
nueva york' mamen sal
[Música]
marisa es experta en diamantes
lleva más de 20 años al frente de este
negocio
los anillos de diamantes los hacemos
aquí pero el diamante viene de canadá o
áfrica
sabe por dónde ha llegado su producto al
país pero imposible descubrir de dónde
han sido extraídos los minerales la
teoría es que rusia podría estar usando
una tercera nación para introducir sus
piedras preciosas en eeuu luego de la
prohibición que hiciera joe biden a los
productos rusos después del ataque a
ucrania
este país de entrada podría ser un día
donde se pulen y cortan el 95% de los
diamantes del mundo
no sé exactamente de dónde vienen pero
sí sé que son 100% diamantes en una
situación similar se espera que ocurra
con el pescado y el marisco rusos que
entrará en este país a través de china
para que se haga una idea el año pasado
según la comisión de comercio
internacional el 50 por ciento del
cangrejo rojo importado a eeuu procedía
de china pero fue capturado en rusia en
el 2021 eeuu importó productos
extranjeros por valor de más de 2
cientos 83 mil millones de dólares de
los cuales 3000 millones procedían de
rusia alrededor de un 11% como estas
patas de cangrejo paul como uno de los
mariscos más populares que llegan de
rusia eeuu este tipo de cangrejos
siempre llega a congelado gracias a que
se distribuyen congeladas todavía hay
existencias pero poco van a durar locos
los proveedores locales tienen mucho
inventario que viene congelado por lo
que por ahora no hay problemas para
conseguir el producto pero seguimos
preguntando qué va a pasar y nadie tiene
una respuesta en ese momento le tiene
claro que en sus estanterías no habrá
productos rusos infiltrados
y no está disponible no podemos ir a la
fábrica y hacer más tenemos que lidiar
con ello una falta de producto que
impactará directamente en el bolsillo
del cliente en todos los sectores ahora
con la prohibición de entrada de
diamantes rusos los precios pueden
aumentar aún más sólo por la demanda
son los efectos de una guerra que aunque
está a miles de kilómetros de distancia
afecta a todo el mundo incluyendo a las
propias exportaciones rusas vamos a
revisar las cifras de la semana 44 mil
millones de dólares esa es la cifra por
la que hilo más cerró un acuerdo de
compra de la red social 'twitter' el
multimillonario fundador de tesla
promete que proteger a la libertad de
expresión y traer a los esperados
cambios como el fin de los bots y un
botón de edición veamos quién es y lo
más que en el siguiente perfil que
preparamos para ustedes
[Aplausos]
al inaugurar una gigantesca nueva
fábrica de tesla y los modos que es
recibido por un coro de pintores en
digno de una estrella de rock
nombrado persona del año por la revista
'time' en 2021 moscú es la persona más
rica del mundo con un valor neto
estimado de 266 mil millones de dólares
según forbes
cual
a parte de su empresa con el lucrativo
fabricante de automóviles eléctricos el
empresario es mejor conocido por fundar
el fabricante de cohetes que spacex
las ambiciones de moss no terminan en la
tierra
podemos traer la vida como la conocemos
y dar vida a martín donde no existe hoy
y asegurarnos de que si hay algún evento
catastrófico en la tierra la vida tal y
como la conocemos continuará existiendo
porque usted
nacido en sudáfrica en 1971 nos mostró
un interés temprano en la tecnología y
talento para el espíritu empresarial con
tan sólo 12 años creó y vendió un
videojuego a una revista de informática
y se mudó a canadá cuando era
adolescente antes de estudiar física y
economía en eeuu luego en 1999 cofundó
lo que pronto se conocería como paypal
el multimillonario pareció fijar su
mirada en twitter a principios de abril
el 4 de abril se convirtió en el
accionista con mayor participación de la
empresa con un 92 por ciento más tarde
ofreció 43 mil millones de dólares por
la red social dando una mejor libertad
de expresión como motivación ha
expresado una serie de propuestas para
el sitio cómo relajar sus restricciones
de contenido que provocaron la
suspensión de la cuenta del expresidente
donald trump
siempre ha sido su plataforma de
elección pero ahora es él quien
realmente intenta ser dueño de la
plataforma tomarla en privado y cambiar
eso
braden ginger a pesar de su discurso
sobre la libertad de expresión
moscú ha sido criticado por burlarse de
un informante de tesla y llamar a un
rescatista que ayudó a salvar a los
niños en la cueva inundada chico pedo
gracias por acompañarme en esta emisión
de aquí américa en la producción
estuvieron luís fernando montes y
natalia cabrera recuerden que pueden ver
esta misión y las anteriores en nuestra
página web www punto frente y 4 punto
con quédense con nosotros
[Música]